what do you wish you'd known before
starting down this screenwriting path
hmm I wish I had known how difficult it
would be and how much of my life would
my choice not complaining would be given
up for it and wouldn't have it any other
way I could change a few things in the
past but that's only because of lack of
the experience and knowledge that you
have now you can only look back and say
I would never have done that or why did
I blow that opportunity you know which
in my book I have those kind of stories
and also disciplines about that and you
know you never even whatever level you
get to you still make mistakes and you
still go well I'd you know should have
done that or but you hopefully make
fewer of them but just to realize how I
mean out of film school you know the
spec was crazy money was going for specs
and we all thought we would just you
know write a good spec and have a career
you know and some did and but the the
amount of time it takes and how it can
affect your life you know the pursuit of
this like I was thinking recently that I
don't know if I would today if I was 11
years old that I would go hmm you know
but she I can't say because I only have
hindsight but I don't know if I would
pursue it today
you know the business constantly evolves
and changes and I always say well I wish
I had worked in the 40s as a writer you
know we've been you know of course like
in the one movie everybody's looking
back at a different year with
romanticize oh the 40's weren't in you
should have been a writer in the 30s 30s
well pretty much before then movies
weren't around you know twenties okay
but you know and then authors were the
big thing you know so we always look
back but the main thing I think was
which I tell writers today you know this
is gonna be a long haul you don't think
it is for you I know it
you know you don't you're gonna be
different and you could be but it's
gonna be a long haul just for everybody
if you talk to anybody and you know on
your videos that you interview everybody
everybody has a different story of how
they and I don't like to say make it
because you never make it in my opinion
you know we're always looking for a next
job you know we are
there's writers you're on a TV show the
show ends you get residuals great but
you got to get your next gig you always
gigging you're always looking for you
know unless you have your own production
company and a funnel of money then you
can call all the shots but you're always
looking for your next job so making it
is getting your next job and the first
one I always say is the hardest but the
second one is pretty pretty difficult
too and then your third and then your
fourth and fifth and you're like oh wow
and they're not always in in sequence
meaning they don't they don't always
come right after each other their
periods that are dry and not for lack of
trying
it's just the nature of the beast about
the business there'll be slow periods
and they'll be oh my gosh I've got so
much work I don't even know what to do
you know and everyone everyone's journey
is gonna be different of how they break
in and so I was saying earlier but
networking you know extremely important
about getting getting those
relationships and not and and not just
being Minoo oh you're my contact I
expect you to help me be a good contact
help people out if you can you know I've
done it so many times when somebody I
see a guy they didn't know I called hey
you better call so and so they've got a
they got the job now they said oh it's
because of you I go no it's because of
you but I just happen to see that
opportunity and tell you about it you
know and people remember that do you
remember completely for years and years
that you know my a friend of mine still
to this day says you got me five years
on a TV show I said nah it wasn't me cuz
no no if you and he knew he knew the
producer anyway but he wasn't in the
right time right place and all I did is
bring it up and it had a dinner and I
said hey what's going on I said well
he's actually looking for work
really why don't you even give me a call
it was that easy or it's that difficult
if you're not at that dinner
somebody else is gonna get that job now
of course he has experience and all that
stuff we're not talking about that but
we're talking about the absolute weird
you know somebody leaves home and you
know at nine o'clock and if they left at
9:30 the bus wouldn't have hit them we
don't know but it's weird stuff going on
you know so yeah even if you were able
to look back at age 11 or whenever it
was let's suppose you chose a different
route and that was to be you know have
your own carpet cleaning business and
you were the best carpet cleaner in all
of your you know the the tri-city area
do you think that you'd be standing in
that same spot saying I don't know this
was really much harder than I thought
don't don't do you think that for every
profession somebody goes to or any any
endeavor that most people say the same
thing that it was much harder than I
thought
yes but I think the film business even
more so because I don't you love the
carpet cleaning business but no you know
I don't know how 50,000 scripts a year
or bouncing her on it you know what I
mean everybody's trying to do the same
thing at least in LA many people are and
across the world everywhere because you
know ever wants to be a filmmaker you
know it's something they said oh
everybody wants to be a filmmaker really
oh okay
great when I was 11 not everybody wanted
to be a filmmaker you know we we had our
little weird click you know of maybe
five of us but we were looked upon as
you know the film nerds like film you
know you know what I mean so it's the
democratization of filmmaking because
it's accessible to everybody so we all
can try it that's absolutely great but
then you learn if you really have a
passion for it and you can but then
there's that other thing about getting a
job you know you can make your own movie
that's fantastic but something you have
to you know as people make movies and
it's on Amazon and that's fine and I
know how many clicks it gets you know if
you want a wide range or something you
know it depends on how how you set your
goals and a lot of times is the more you
you know you get knocked around in the
business many times your what's your
vision of what it was changes just by
the fact of you know you get older you
know and you start to be like wow okay
well I wanted to hit for that you know
this and you go I'm okay with this you
know you know I mean things change from
what you originally thought at eleven
but you got to keep that wide-eyed
dreamer alive otherwise it's all gone so
that 11 year old kid is still in here
somewhere even though the jaded person
is you know but you got to keep that
inside of you because that would keeps
you going you know like like we were
talking about going to a movie theater
and the popcorn and the lights go down
and you like take me and and you're like
the magic of cinema the movies you know
and that's just what I just clicked with
me it wasn't Carpet Cleaning it wasn't
being a lawyer it was that's what I want
to do and thank God I had a friend who
got a camera and maybe I would have you
know he eventually got one of my own
but that spark sort of clicked at the
same time you know so who knows I mean
who's to say and I had very supportive
parents that's also important you know
who said go for it you know we never got
to do what we wanted and it's gonna be
tough but we'll be you're said you know
to back you up and that that helps to
have someone in your corner who believes
in you rather than you know has the the
doubts and you know whispers in your
know what do you think you're gonna sell
something yeah you're right all right I
may as well give it up now you know get
a refund for that software you know you
think jade is being and I'm not saying
you're jaded I'm not joking
wait but there is a level that's needed
don't you think to self progressed
protective layers sure absolutely and it
only comes from getting like I say
knocked around so the wide-eyed kid on
one side and the you know the Box are on
the other going I'm gonna you know
because I've been down that road before
I've been
that situation I was taken advantage of
because I allowed it because I didn't I
wasn't smart enough not smart enough but
I didn't have the information I needed
to say no and no is an okay thing to say
when you say this isn't for me you're
dangling you know carrots and riches and
it's I'm walking away and I did to a
certain extent with that speck a company
wanted to buy it outright and you know
tell me to walk away and you know I
needed the money at the time sure it
would have been it's not you know
life-changing money there was who's to
say but it was sort of like yeah okay I
can make Matt and you know how many
months doing my waiting job you know but
I wasn't gonna walk away I said this
doesn't feel right for me I'm gonna just
I'm gonna just take this back and you
know someday somebody will find it and
they did and it happens and it doesn't
happen but there's no guarantees in this
business but the only guarantee is I
always say is the mantra is that if you
if you stop writing
you really guaranteed to have no chance
of success so you can only look in the
mirror and complain to yourself if
you're not doing the work and you know
you can blame Hollywood you can blame
your agents you can blame you know I'm a
victim above uh know if you're not doing
the work then you only have yourself to
blame and the minute you stop doing the
work then you're out of the game you're
in the game doesn't mean if you sold
something or not as long as you're
writing screenplays and you've got it
you've got a cohesive plan and you've
got a schedule I was reading something
recently writers said yeah I've do three
scripts a year I'm like that's great I
did three last year assignments but and
you know tried to work on a spec but
okay but if you have a plan of what
you're gonna do not just not have a plan
and kind of wing it time goes by so fast
you know you turn around it's five years
you're like oh wow what happened you
know every year reevaluate I'm on my
blog I have a year-end checklist it has
seven points and it says reevaluate the
last year don't beat yourself up
but learn from it what should you excel
in what did you fail in you know where
where's your strengths and weaknesses
like we were talking about for writers
what do you have to improve on you know
take it seriously not just I'm gonna
write a script you know because it's you
it's you incorporated you know there's
no one out there is no one out there
pushing you and we all decided to go
down this journey no one forced any of
us you know so you have to take
responsibility for yourself and also you
know your career plans employ what you
know you're what you're gonna do you
know do you write down all of some of
the things that you thought you could
improve on or you just put that out
there like for 2019 the end did you put
down specific things that you owe in the
blog yes we did okay what were some of
those things that you either could have
done better or that you were really
happy that you did well you know what
projects did you work on what did you
have in your arsenal was the scripts it
was the TV pilots was it pitches was
outlines you know in your in your folder
of where wherever it is in your computer
what's in your arsenal what do you got
you know and what are you working on and
what's gonna be finished first and what
do you think you know you got to
strategize and what are you gonna do
with that script what are your plans I'm
going to enter Nicholl fellowship great
I'm gonna do this and that fantastic
I've got a contact at blah blah blah you
know so now you have a you have a goal
and you said set those those goals and
okay where did you fail what did you
make mistakes on okay I sent this script
out too early you know they gave me
horrendous notes you know all right I
had it I'd failed I didn't get in this
festival or whatever that's again
festivals are whole nother story but you
can't look at his failure if you didn't
win a festival but I'm just saying
things that you failures that you would
you expected to happen in a positive
manner that didn't that's what I mean
about that or outright failures they
rejected the script and said it was
horrible
you know
thinks things of those that nature and
we and then you know with networking who
did I meet you know keep keep a log of
that and and follow up new your new
years it was a great is a great time to
send out that email hey you know always
look for a reason not just a cold call
email to somebody you may have met it's
like hey yeah we just wanted which you
Happy New Year just I hope your projects
doing well I happen to be working on
this in Bible but you know things like
that of that nature
cards are old-school but they're great
way again if you get that card you know
the I was told that the assistants put
the handwritten cards on top of the mail
so when the mail comes in the
handwritten stuffs on top so whose card
is going to be there
hey happy new year and you're like hey
Mark guy you know yes right it's taking
you to the studio exactly huh so you
know you remember that mark guy yeah you
know puts you back on the radar and it's
old-school emails like so cold and and
you know so various things like that
where you you look over the past year
and analyze it honestly and and then
what are you gonna do this year you know
what do you have plans I mean the year
goes by fast so what are you doing you
know instead of like well you know I set
up set up a schedule I want to finish
the script by March 1st and dammit if
I'm not gonna meet that and I've get I
only have to do two pages a day great
rain or shine
just like talking about studying martial
arts rain or shine my my Sifu says did
you study today I said yes
okay don't and boy do talk about
procrastination it's like yeah it's late
you know you know last night I did my my
training and I didn't want to but it
becomes ingrained where then you do want
to and then when you see results of that
you want to even more because nothing's
done if you don't do it I mean it sounds
so simple but the same way with writing
you know so by March 1st I don't want to
hear somebody who committed to that made
a self commitment to them
which is the worst thing for me to break
a commitment to myself because you know
I don't like to do it to others but to
yourself and you you yeah unless
something terrible comes up right but
you finish it by March you're like damn
I can hit a deadline you know and I'm
not expecting it to be amazing but I got
a first draft done and now what are you
gonna do with I'm gonna go through the
thing and you know you know what I mean
so it's just being aware of just not
like treating it like a business almost
you know of like we have to have plans
for this thing that's you the
screenwriter to get you to these
different levels so would you say that
you are a working screenwriter seven
days a week in terms of you work on your
career in one fashion or something I say
screenwriters don't get weekends off and
this weekend will be exactly the case
because today and before I came I got
notes again from a Polish of a script
I've been you know I wrote an assignment
and you know I want to turn it around as
fast as possible because I want the
thing made and so you know and there's
sometimes but something in my life
always has to do with screenwriting you
know something always is something you
can't just there are times when I can be
away from it but then I start getting
antsy you know because I like to work
and I like to create so yeah it's a big
it's a big part which is the way I've
planned it you know I want it to be a
big part of what I do so
you